well it's fairly busy and I was just
walking across the bridge when suddenly
a bus stopped right in front of me and
everybody started screaming and I saw a
trainer in the road and first of all I
train rising a shoe a shoe yeah and I
thought somebody must've been hit by a
car and then I saw a body on the other
side of the road and then there was
another body further up and then when I
looked over the side of the bridge there
was another body lying in the water now
any indication as to what had caused
those people to be injured I mean had
you seen a car come through or a no I
didn't see anything the first thing I
was aware of was just people starting to
scream and people came off the bus
looking very shocked and then everybody
there was a lot of confusion and people
started dealing with with the casualties
and at that point I just tried to stop
people coming onto the bridge because
still a lot of people were coming on how
did you do that how did you try and stop
people from coming on the bridge just
trying to wave them back and you know
and I think people could tell because
people were screaming that something
something bad was happening forgive me
just to go back did you say a body in
the water did you use yes so a body
someone had fallen off the bridge see
who knows but it seemed that way yeah
and they were lying face down in the
water okay and then what happened after
that after that there was a kind of a
pause and it seemed very confused for
quite a long time and then a medic
arrived on an on a bike and then
ambulances ride fairly quickly after
that and then the police started pouring
under the bridge and at that point we
walked we walked people off the bridge
and they put a tape around it
did you hear noises that sounded like
gunshots I didn't know I hope afterwards
I've heard people say that I didn't hear
that I just heard the scream yeah I live
in the student accommodation about
hundred meters away from the south side
of Westminster Bridge I walked out to go
to the University and I think some of my
age came to me and says there's been a
terrorist attack on the bridge and sorry
I ran over and I whipped up the bridge
so he wants know what had happened and
unfortunately seen some pretty terrible
can you within the bounds of decency
tell us what you did see I saw three
poor people roughly who had been hit by
a car and some car parts on the road and
stuff you're pretty sure they'd been hit
by a car yes yeah that was that was the
conclusion I made based on what focus
people are as well people were talking
it was the noise I heard first of all
him appeared to be like gunshot wounds
I'm not saying that there were and then
I just saw a car go out of control and
just go into pedestrians and
and then obviously the boss is still
moving and so as we go in across the
bridge and we saw people lying on the
floor that are the injured
but
so about 10 10 people baby
[Music]
started to around them it's just
everyone's just running everywhere just
to worm to him